[Music]
sometimes a simple tweak to an already
existing object can change our lives
forever but it's even better when you
get introduced to a brand new invention
you didn't even know you needed in your
life electronics eco-friendly ways to
drink water and multifunctional products
that save space and time these are the
inventions that will forever change your
daily habits like our video make sure
you click that subscribe button to keep
up with our content now let's explore
some of the 10 brilliant inventions that
will change your life
Solar suction cup charger this might be
one of the most revolutionary chargers
you will ever come across
it's called Rey and it's a solar charger
with an added suction cup it also comes
with a stand so you don't really have to
stick it on a window it is one of the
best eco-friendly chargers on the market
this is an amazing choice for travelers
for those living in a sunny climate you
can also attach it to your airplane
window and charge your phone while in
the air tour buses trains and long car
rides are now great opportunities to
charge your phone this is one of the
best life saving gadgets you never knew
you needed with many solar chargers
currently on the market you'll easily
find one with ports made for all your
devices cameras and Apple product a USB
device it doesn't matter just make sure
you explain what you're doing to anyone
who might wonder why you're sticking
around looking device with wires on an
airplane window the Chargers are
currently available in almost every
gadget store but the best also come with
a handy foreign one charging cable for
all your devices water balls it's a
brand new invention and probably a very
interesting look into the future the
idea behind water balls comes from
wanting to reduce plastic waste that's
created by water bottles so how can you
enjoy your water without having it in a
bottle with water balls that go by the
name oh ho
they are shaped in a small transparent
sphere and filled with either natural or
flavored water the balls are first being
introduced in the United States and
England and they are already adored by
the public with pollution in big cities
getting bigger and bigger the new way of
drinking water comes in handy
the Ojo water balls resembled
and are completely biodegradable if you
don't consume them after four to six
weeks they will decompose compared to
this a plastic water bottle can take
hundreds of years to finally decompose
the startup company behind the product
claims that although this is not a
permanent solution it will definitely
provide results for short-term
consumption the company behind the
products skipping rock slab says that
they are trying to match the water
consumption time with its packaging
ironing board mirror in a world where
the living spaces are getting smaller
and smaller multifunctional household
items come in handy meet the ironing
board that pulls up into a full sized
mirror it was made by a French designer
who decided it's time we put that
ironing board to good use instead of
wasting space in your laundry room you
can simply turn the board and reveal a
full-length mirror on its bottom side if
you worried about its stability you
really don't have to the ironing board
mirror is designed the same way as your
regular ironing board the two sides that
are supporting the board lock when being
used and enable safe ironing and then
all you have to do is move them to their
free turning position turn the board
vertically and voila you have your
mirror this is a fantastic way of saving
space and putting your ironing board to
constant use the ironing board mirror
also works perfectly for people on the
go iron your clothes put them on fold
your board and check yourself out in the
mirror
I use Sailaja row the designer behind
this product is also a co-founder of a
French design studio that gives a
practical spin to many commonly used
household objects but we can't stop
being in love with this ironing board
mirror bladeless fan in 2009 the dyson
company that's famous for their vacuum
cleaners introduced one of the most
innovative and insanely futuristic
products yet it is a fan that can cool
you off without any blades to its
structure yep that's right when you turn
it on nothing moves but wait how is that
thing even producing air bed the
pedestal of the fan contains a motor
that mixes air in the same way the
blades do on your regular cooling fan
the original bladeless fan presented by
dyson did have a problem what do you
think it was
if you guessed noise you were right
because of the way it was
find the Moto inside the fan got pretty
loud they decided to redesign the old
version and created a soundproof chamber
around the motor that muffles the loud
noise then the company stepped it up
even further and also introduced heaters
humidifiers and air purifiers they are
all controllable with the remote or they
can automatically turn and be set to a
timer one of the best things about the
playlist then is that it is also
child-friendly no more kids will be
poking around the fans in the house
couples alarm clock got a significant
other that has to wake up way earlier
than you do but his annoying alarm clock
wakes you up - not anymore
this unique and extremely elegant
product was designed to transform the
waking process of couples it's called
ring and although it's still a concept
design it's making a buzz around the
world it is an alarm clock that wakes
people up with a gentle vibration
instead of using sound this also works
for anyone who has difficulty hearing
alarm clocks in the first place the
alarm clock is actually a part of two
rings that are worn on the finger pad
which are the most sensitive parts of a
hand both couples can set their own
separate waking times go to sleep with a
ring on their finger and wake up with a
sound free vibration the base of the
alarm clock is also used as a charging
station then all you have to do is just
get out of bed try not to make too much
noise and let your partner snooze for
another hour - amazing isn't it another
option is also the popular alarm clock
that wakes you up with natural light
which prepares your body to wake up and
start your day ping pong door speaking
of multifunctional household objects
this will make any apartment and any
office look 10 times cooler want to cool
off but can't leave the room how about a
game of ping pong right on your door yup
on your door this ping pong door is a
clever way to bring some fun into a busy
office schedule designed by a German
designer this is a space-saving solution
as well as a way to fight the boredom it
looks like just a regular door and it
opens and shuts like a regular door but
you'll notice that it's bright green and
has a stripe down the middle
an attached net across it all you need
to do is put it in its horizontal state
and the door transforms into an awesome
ping pong table the door frame will
remain in place for extra sturdiness of
course this table isn't made for any
professional ping-pong players but it's
an excellent way to take a break from
your work but if you can't spare 350
dollars for a ping pong door this should
be an inspiration to turn your door into
an awesome playing board baby mop this
product started off as a joke on a
Japanese commercial and later on SNL but
some jokes can be easily turned into an
actual practical product meet baby mop
worried about the duster baby picks up
as they crawl on the floor this product
is made for tired parents and
hyperactive babies let your child freely
crawl around the floor knowing they're
also doing household chores as in Rome
about the cute little outfit perfectly
fits toddlers and comes with velour
fabric and added dusting strings on legs
and arms the onesies are designed for
crawling toddlers and made from snuggly
soft cotton while this is considered a
funny baby shower or birthday gift it
really took off the director behind the
website better than pants calm said that
the sale suddenly hit double digits in
no time the website gave several reasons
as to why this is the perfect gift they
say that your child will get a nice
workout burn off more energy and sleep
much better the baby mop can also be
found on Amazon in colors like red and
light blue so cute laser-guided scissors
how annoying is it when you cut out a
shape and then find out you went
completely out of line unless you have a
steady hand and plenty of time and
patience cutting straight lines with
scissors can be challenging do you avoid
gift wrapping because you just can't
deal with cutting straight lines with
scissors this is where laser-guided
scissors come in no more drawing lines
using rulers the laser-guided scissors
come with an attached laser that clearly
marks your cutting pad these are
particularly useful for large projects
and can even work on fabric or any other
clothing material they're also popular
during the holiday season and your kids
will be happy knowing they can help
perfectly cut and wrap presents for your
family dress making gift wrapping scrap
King and Kraftwerk are now a piece of
cake no more wasting material because of
an uneven cut the blades are sharp and
can effortlessly slide through the paper
without any issues and the best part
they're affordable the cheapest
laser-guided scissors we could find for
only five dollars LED slippers one of
the best life-changing inventions for
anyone who needs to make trips to the
bathroom in the middle of the night
these are LED lights on each slipper
this product is pretty simple but it can
make your life so much easier just put
them on and go on your way without
having to turn on the lights and wake up
your entire household and what's even
better is that after you step out of
your slippers the lights go off with a
delay giving you enough time to climb
back into bed perfect for people making
regular night trips to the bathroom and
even better for couples with night jobs
you can now easily move around or work
in the middle of the night without
having the light wake up your partner
and no more stepping on your kids toys
in the dark the LED slippers are
comfortable and soft perfect for any
season alternatively you can also make
your own using a needle and thread
nice scissors and of course LED lights
the LED slippers come at an affordable
price of twenty dollars glass toaster
tell us how do you like your toast in
the morning lightly toasted or golden
brown and how many times have you burned
your toast during breakfast not anymore
not only does it look modern this
toaster is made of glass you won't burn
your toast anymore
you can now clearly see what's happening
in the toaster and make the toast
perfect for you blast toasters are very
affordable and now come with many
toasting functions you also get a stop
button to control the toaster if you
notice your toast is being done just
right unlike the toasters you know glass
toasters come with the intelligent
thermo glass technology that evens out
the Browning their bread carriage rises
and falls automatically it's a lot
smoother and comes with a sound once
your toast is done and ready to be
served they also have the usual bread
crumb tray and an extra lever that lifts
higher unless you remove smaller pieces
that are usually left in the toaster
checkout the glass toaster by Maggi mix
that lets
you open the double insulated glass
windows and clean them in no time
who's ready for some morning toast
what's the one invention you're waiting
for let us know in the comments below
don't forget to like this video and
subscribe to our channel for more
inventions and life hacks you really
need in your life check out 10 coca-cola
hacks that actually work see you in the
next video
[Music]